あの順番で今日は執着についてお話しさせていただきます
あの要約にあったように
この未練があるとなかなか苦しいという話ですが
人間というのは あの いろんなものについていろいろ未練があるんですよ
で まあ最初はまあ自分の親やらね
自分のおもちゃとかね
食べるものとか まあそういうところから執着が始まります
で 一旦子供にでもおもちゃあげたらね
それは喜んじゃったら
まあなかなか手放しはしない
で 私たちもまあ子供を一応騙しておくために
あの強引に まあ無意味なおもちゃなんかにね
ぬいぐるみなんかに執着させて
寝る時でもそばに置いておいて
時々それは病気になって
二十歳になってもぬいぐるみがないと寝られない人もいます
女性はともかく 男の場合も結構ありますからね
で まあそこまでまあ勝手にどうでもいいんだけど
そこで危険な部分もあります
人間死ぬ時もなかなか未練捨てきれないで死ぬんですよ
全ての未練 まあ終わったと亡くなったというふうな状態で
清々しい気持ちで死ぬ人っていうのはめったにない
まあほとんどない でもないんですよ
いるはずもないんです
で 未練があったら今世で苦しむだけではなくて
問題っていうのは この死ぬ時もすごいいろんなことに未練があって
やり残したことがあって死にますから
それから不幸になっちゃうんですね
まあ一回死んだだけで
全てパーに無になるんだったらありがたいんですけどね
物事っていうのはそうやっても全く無になるっていうことはないんですね
変化はあるんだけどね
今のあるものは変化して違うものになるという
限りなく変化していく
だから消えた なくなった
もう終わったという真空状態に真空状態になるということはありえないんです
ですから 心っていうのはもうしっかりしたエネルギーで
ものすごい巨大なパワーなんですよ
で 私たちはね 体を動かしたり
しゃべったりするのは心のエネルギーなんですね
で これぐらいの機械を作って年間動かそうと思ったらどれぐらい大変かと
工学的に考えちゃうと皆さんはわかるでしょうね
手を上げたり下げたりすること
歩いたり 喋ったり 見たり
考えたりすることを機械にやらせちゃうと
80年間は持てませんね
いくら修理してもせいぜい10年で壊れてしまいますよ
ですから この物体を80年間
あるいはもっと長く 100
年間でもね なんとか動かして起動させている
あの巨大なエネルギーが心なんです
ですから この体ばかにしたっても
心はばかにしてはいけません
で みんなすごい軽々く心のエネルギーっていうのはもう大したことないと思ってますけど
それでそうじゃないんです
もう大変なエネルギーなんです
で 創造接する力を持ってます
ただ汚れているんだから
我々にはそれわからない
わからなくても 今の説明から見ると
体機械に例えてみて 単なる物体として見て
この物体がずっと80年以上ぐらいね
動いてるでしょうに それはどちらの力かと
その年齢はどこから来るんですかと
それはまあ純粋に心の力なんですね
ですから 心というものも瞬間瞬間変化する
体より早く変化する 体変化するためにはかなり時間がかかります
で 生まれた人間が大人になるためには
一応年はかかります 子供の時だけは早く変わるんだけど
それからゆっくり体っていうのはゆっくり変わりますね
でも心っていうのはものすごい早く変わってしまっちゃうんですね
笑っている人を泣かせるためにそんな時間はかかりません
ニコニコと笑っている人は怒らせようと思ったらね
泣かせることは難しいかもしれませんけど
怒らせることは瞬時にできますね
ですから たった一日会っただけでもね
今日善人のようなようにいた人が
たった一日だけ頭を変えれば
次の日は殺人者にもなりかねません
それぐらい心っていうのはものすごい勢いで変化する
それもまた巨大なエネルギーですね
だからその心がすごい未練があって
ものすごく重くて 死んじゃうと先もものすごい暗いんですよ
この執着の一番の危険なところは
このまあ輪廻のことなんですね
ものすごい怖いところは
まあこの世の中においては
もうなんとかなんとかもう頑張れますけど
執着があっても でもその時はすごいショックを受けちゃうんですよ
死にたくはないんです
で まあそろそろ死ぬだな
死ぬだなと思ったら 生まれて初めてすごいひどい精神的なショックを受けて怖くなって震えて
他の人にわからないんですよ
震えたくても体が動かないんだから
死ぬ時だから それでさらにショックが強いんですよ
例えば 嫌だ 怖いんだとか言って体を動かしたり
もういろいろなことをできれば
いくらかそこでエネルギーは発散しますよ
で もしかすると体が麻痺状態になったりとかね
大体もう死ぬ時はもう寝たきりで何もできませんだからね
その時は心だけ すごい恐怖感を我慢しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから まあなかなかこれは危険であって
大変危険というよりもものすごい怖いことなんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃるんですよ
人々にとってはものすごい恐るべきことというのは
そういうことだと こんなまあ遊んで生活したっても
あまりにも乗り越えられないほどの怖いことが待ってるんですよ
それは死ぬことではなく
死ぬ時の心なんですよ
そういうことだから 最初からもうこの執着っていうのは大変な危険なものだと覚えておいた方が
まあいくらか未練消えるだろうと思います
ですから この 今日は執着している何か知恵がないかという話ですから
執着のついてよりもね
そういうことだから やっぱり
大体年取ってくると なかなかこの自慢できるような生き方であるならばね
死ぬ時は何のことなく
まあ自慢しながら死ねるんだったら
結構執着というのは少ないんですよ
この自慢という言葉はおかしい言葉でね
ちょっと気をつけないと
この自慢というのは この
やっぱり自分としては恥ずかしくないと
いろいろいいことをしましたと
という自分で自分を褒められる状態なんですね
人に褒められることもあてにならないんですよ
人の褒め方っていうのは
まあほとんど口先だけで褒める場合もあるし
あるいは誤解して褒めるべきではないものも褒める時あるしね
ですから 人に褒められることっていうのは
それほどあてにならない
人に褒められるんだったら
聖なる人々 知恵のある人々
ものすごい知識人が褒めるんだったら
まあそれはいくらかあてになります
でも いつでも我々は知識人で清らかな人々に囲まれているわけじゃないんだからね
極普通のお互いによく知ってる人々に囲まれているんだから
あてにならないんですよ
褒めても ですから 自分で自分のことを褒められるかという生き方
今日から始めると もう大丈夫だとということになるんですね
死ぬ時はやることはないんだと
そういうふうな生き方をしておけば
かなり人間の今世においても人生は幸せになるし
で 死ぬ時も幸せに死ぬし
死んでからも大変幸せな生まれ変わりがあるんですね
だから心が重くなるとどうしても下へ行くんでしょ
重いものはね これは物質と同じですね
働きが 心は物質ではありません
だけど やっぱりもう下へ下へ
低次元に低次元に行くんですね
だから 例えば性格悪い人とかね
余計な悪いことばっかりする人々の人生を見ると
どんどん暗くなって 社会から離れて
暗くなって 不幸になって
もう影も薄くなって もうなんとなくもういてもいなくてもどうでもいいということになるでしょうね
例えば犯罪する人々なんか
社会なんかもうあんたは社会にいてほしくないとという約束がありまして
追い出すでしょうね 社会から離れて別な場所に
刑務所というところに入れちゃう
入れて そこで人権 権利まで取り消す
人間としては扱わない
だからこの そういうことは我々に見えてますから
心は重くなると上に行くということはないんですよ
だから執着によって心は重くなっちゃいますね
すごく そういうことで上に行くということはありえないんですね
それはすごい厳密な論理的なことで
世の中を見てみるとね
やっぱり欲深い人やら怒り深い人やらね
で まあ成功するわけでもないしね
うまくいくわけでもないし
優しい人  自分のことをあんまりそんなに真剣に考えないで
みんなのことも考える人とかね
どんどんどんどん軽く生きていて
まあ上上と行っちゃいますね
やはり死ぬ時でも その人はさらに上に行ってしまうんですよ
だからそういう論理なんですけど
なかなか物に対する執着っていうのは捨てきれないということは
我々の弱みなんですね
そこであの執着といえば
あの まず物に対する執着
我々はいろんなものに囚われていますね
ものといえば まあ物質だけではなくて
人に対する執着も同じことなんですね
ですから 人々っていうのは
家やら財産 家族 会社 そういういろんなものに執着する
それはどういうことかと
よく反論で言うのは そういうものがなければ生きていられないのではないかと
家族があったら幸せじゃないんですらないかと
お金があったら幸せではないかと
という反論するんですよ
で 仕事があった方が幸せじゃないんですかと
友達がいた方が幸せじゃないかと
だから何言うんですかと
そこで私は逆に反論したいんですよ
そんなことわからないと思ってるんですかと
執着は良くないという人々は
それぐらいのこともわかってない
頭の悪いアホですかね
だからそんな単純なことをお釈迦様はわかってなかったんですかね
人間が土地があったら
そこで畑を耕して もうおいしくお腹いっぱい三食食べてるんだと
家があるともう雨に触れないで
雪に触れないで 風邪に体を守っていることをお釈迦様は知らなかったんですかね
だからそんな反論っていうのはあまりにも当てにならない反論なんですよ
だからまあ そこでこの一つの手段として言いたいのは
それはもう物事を知り尽くした人が良くないと言うんだから
そちらに何かあるんじゃないかと
ただの誰かが言うんだったら
まあいい加減にしなさいと
例えば勉強もしたことがないと
学校にも行ったことがないとか
人からものを乞うで食べている人とかね
性格も行儀も悪いいい加減な人が言うならばね
例えば自分が人生失敗してホームレスになってホームレスになっちゃって
そこでみんなに説教するんだったらね
そんな採算会社なんかいちめんどくさいんですよと
私は全部やめましたよと
君らもやめなさいと言ったら
当てにする必要ないんですよ
私なんかは小学校にも行ったことがないんだと
だからもう別に勉強する必要は何もないんだと
って言ったって それを当てにする必要ないんですよ
でもこれ こういうことをおっしゃっているのはお釈迦様ですからね
人生の失敗者ではなかったんだからね
そういうことだから 何か大事な意味があるんだと
ということを覚えておいた方が
まだ実践しやすいと思います
で そこで物に対する執着
それはどのような働きがありますかというと
で 私が何か欲しいと思ったら
それから苦労して その欲しがるものを得なくちゃいけないんですよ
で 得たとしても じゃあ自分が希望するような感じで
希望したような通りにそのものから幸せを得られますか？っていう
それから得たものもどんどん変化しているんだからね
いくんだから 例えば 服を買っても高いお金で
もう二 三回着たらもう使えなくなるぐらいの高ければ高いほどそういうことなんですね
1,000円  2,000円で買ったものは洗い
洗って洗っても2 3年は着られますけどね
10万  20万のものはそうはいかないんです
ですから このそれはすぐ消えてしまうんですよ
そうするとすごい悔しいんですね
もう一つ大事なポイントは
それでもなくて もう一つ大事なポイントがあるんですね
私たちは自分の幸せはものにありと
お金にあると 家にあると思っているんですよ
結婚したら私は幸せですよというと
自分の幸せは結婚にあるんですよ
家族がいたら私が幸せですよと思ったら
この家族にあるんですね
幸せが だからものが自分の幸せを作ってくれなくてはいけない状態になっちゃうんです
それで自由に動けなくなっちゃうんですね
私たちの自由はなくなっちゃうんですね
それっきり ものすごい厳密に束縛されるんですよ
で 会社が命だ 家族が命だとか何とかとか思ったらね
まあその人には 1 秒でも自由がなくなっちゃうんです
結局自分が奴隷になるんですよ
ものの奴隷になる なぜならば
そのものが自分に幸せを作ってくれるんだから
そこで幸せというのは
もうとっくに喜びぐらいのものなんですけど
楽しいというぐらいのことですけど
お金があれば幸せという人はお金の奴隷になる
お金が神様になってしまって
で 神様が自分に幸せを与えてくれる
ですから 自分言う通りにお金動くんじゃなくて
お金が言う通りに自分が動かなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば金儲けたいと思ったら
お金にもそれなりの法則があるでしょ
私たちは 自分が金欲しければ
そのお金の法則に従って生活しなくちゃいけない
自分好き勝手にお金入ってこいと言ったっても入ってこないんだからね
お金どんどん入ってこいと言っても入ってこない
それなりの行動をしなくちゃいけない
自分が結婚したと思ったっても
すぐ瞬時に世の中のね
適切な人が飛んでくるわけじゃないんです
自分が一生懸命探さなくちゃいけないんですね
探したところで 向こうは行ってあげるという状態だからね
こちらが向こうの条件をのまなくちゃいけないんですよ
お金の場合も同じなんですよ
じゃああんたのところに行ってあげると
ですから お金の条件を飲み込まなくちゃいけないんですね
大きな家建ったらどうなるんですかね
家が自分の条件持ってますよ
一旦家に住み始めたら
家が言う通りに私たちは生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
私たちが言う通りに家が変化することはないんですね
だからこの執着っていうのは
簡単に人が何もできない完璧な奴隷にすることなんです
そこで自分というものは消えてしまうんですよ
結局は 自分がただ社会に振り回されている道具に過ぎないんですよ
そこで心の中でものすごい葛藤が生まれるんですね
やっぱり自分がいるんだと
自分の意思でも何かやりたいと
という気持ちがずっとあるんですよ
でも それも一度も味わうことはできなくなっちゃうんですね
お釈迦様の時代ではなくて
このジャータカ物語にこの執着についてお釈迦様ある物語があるんです
昔々 まあこれ物語ですけどね
ある人が家も迷惑だと
財産も迷惑ですと 心は汚れるんだと
心清らかにする人にとっては
もうそういうものは迷惑ですと思って
すべて捨てて 森の中に入る
インドの話だから このヒマラヤに入ると
ヘーマワンタパッバタンパーヴィチというアッティマスからヒマラヤに入っちゃうんですね
そこでまあ一つだけ持っていくんですよ
まあ全て捨てても ちょっと腰にちょっと布一切れをね
まあ今の寸法で言えば
もしかすると１メートルぐらい
ちょっとした一切れを持って
それを腰に巻いて まあちょっとまあこの恥ずかしいところを隠すだけ
上は何も着ていない 草履も履いていない
ただそれだけ持って山の中に入る
かえって一生懸命修行するんですよ
で そこで自分であちこち葉っぱやら枝やらも拾ってきて
ちょっとあの小さなね
住むところを作って生活しているんだけど
夜寝て ある日 夜寝て起きてみたら
布一切れを噛まれているんですね
そこで次の日また見たらもっと噛まれているんですよ
誰かと何でしょうかと思ったら
これネズミがいるんです
ネズミがその部屋に入り込んじゃって
布を噛むんですね この人をこう思った
これ大変だと 私にこの布一切れしかないんだからね
これなくなったら裸でいることになっちゃいますよと
どうしよう ネズミを追い出さなくちゃいけない
これ なかなか見つかりませんね
それで考えたのは まあネズミはやっぱり猫に怖いんですね
そこでまた一旦山を下りて村に行って
猫を１匹拾ってきたんですよ
で 拾ってきたら まあ猫を連れて山に入ったところで
まあネズミは怖くなっちゃったんだけど
でも猫は１日２日いて面白くないんですね
食べるものもない この人はもう果物やらね
そういう山にあるものを食べるんだけどね
なかなかバナナ食べる猫とかいないんだからね
だから一旦出家してるんだから
もう修行者だからね 自分でいろいろ取ってあげることもできないし
狩りをして だから猫が自分で餌を探さなくちゃいけないんだから
なかなかいないんですね
なかなか それで困ったと
猫がいなくなっちゃったらネズミが来るんじゃないかと
それで考えたのは 餌さえあればお腹さえね
満腹にしておけば猫はグーグーと寝ているでしょうと思って
猫に餌をあげなくてはならないことになりました
それで彼がもうまた村に入って托鉢をする
と まあこの牛乳とかね
そういうと作っているところに托鉢にしたら行ったら
まああるものをあげるんだから
牛乳とかね そういうものをもらったりする
で そういう適当に猫が食べるものがあるところに托鉢に行ったら
そういうものをもらう
で もらったりするんだけど
そこで帰ってきて１日なくなっちゃうんだ
ですよ それで考えたのは修行には時間なくなったんだ
自分で牛一頭もらってくればいいんじゃないかっていうことで
これは仏教以前のバラモン文化の話だから
そういうものをもらうのは簡単ですね
そこで牛一頭もらってきて
で 山で牛に餌を食べさせて
牛乳を取って猫にあげる
牛の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですね
これから それでその人は考えたのは
これ自分のは修行に来たんだからね
牛の面倒に一日かかっちゃうと困ると言って
村からお手伝いするために男の子を一人連れてくるんです
で その子に君がこの牛の面倒を見なさいと
その代わりにその人は行って托鉢にして
いろいろ二人分托鉢してくるんです
結構時間かかって 男の人は牛の面倒を見る
でも男の人っていうのは面白くないんだから
もう森の中にいるのは
あっちこっち村に行ったりする遊びに
で なかなか帰らなかったりとかね
そこで考えたのは まあこの子はもう若者弟子ですし
今はね ですから 相手がいれば
あっちこっち行かないでいるだろうと思って
またお嫁さんも連れてくるんですよ
そういうふうにどんどん
結局その人の人生はもう台無しになっちゃったんです
みんなの面倒を見なくちゃいけないでしょうに
結局自分が捨てた世界にまた戻って
また大変苦しい世界になってしまったと
そのストーリーを言って
どこで間違ってるんでしょうかと
考え方ですよ あの布一切れに対する執着なんです
これは私のもの これはなくなったらもう大変だと
守らなくちゃいけないんだと
あのたったそれだけの考え方で
せっかく山に入った 家出して出家した人がすべてなくなって
結局還俗することになっちゃったんです
こんなこと言ったって切りがない
まあ一応また戻って 普通にお仕事をして
みんなを養うんだということに元に戻ってしまったんですね
だから 聖なる道を歩むことはできなかったんです
そういうことで この執着にはそういうからくりがあるんです
だから誰にでも これは出家の場合だけではなくて
物に囚われたら もうどんどんどんどん不幸が増えるんであって
幸福が増えるわけじゃないんです
その幸福が増えるということは
ちょっとした錯覚なんですよ
で お母さんたちがよく知ってるでしょ
まあすごい気持ちよく結婚するでしょうに
まあ最高の幸せやと思って
その日からどうですかね
人生は  1 日も休みがないでしょうに
そこで子供育てて大きくなったところで
子供を結婚させたところで
じゃあ休めるかというと
それで孫が出てくるんですよ
自分の子供のことを心配で心配で
孫には子育てできないだろうと思って
孫に手を焼くようになっちゃうんです
で それもなんとか手放すことになっちゃうと
自分がもう動けなくなっちゃって
それで他の人々はもう死ぬまで留守番頼んじゃうんです
みんなあっちこち出かけているんだけど
もう年取ってるおばあちゃんには
じゃあおばあちゃん留守番お願いしますと
だから現代女性はいくらかは自由なんですけど
まあ一般的に言えば一生家に束縛されて家の奴隷にするんでしょうに
避ける方法はないんですよ
で 男性にしたっても同じく自由はないんです
その自由がなぜ失うかというと
このものに囚われているからなんです
そこで問題は じゃあもう全部捨てちゃえばいいかということでしょうかね
だからある人が全部捨てたんだからね
あのストーリーに出てくる人が全部捨てたんだけど
問題は解決しなかったんです
そのあのストーリーは作ったストーリーかもしれませんだけど
厳密に心理学的に考えて作っているストーリーなんですよ
あのバラモン人が全財産捨てて山に入ったんです
本当に正直な気持ちで
禅定を積もって梵天に生まれ変わりたいんだというインチキではなかったんです
でも問題は 彼は物を捨てたんだけど
執着を捨てなかったんですよ
彼が捨てるべきものは捨てないで
捨ててもどうでもいいことは捨てちゃったんです
例えば執着が良くないんだからと自分の子供を捨てるんだと
コインコインロッカーに入れて逃げちゃうんだと
それで執着は消えますかね
消えません 一生あの苦しみは追ってくるんです
自分が子供を捨てたんだと
だからこの邪険になっていい加減に物を捨てても
それは間違ってます あのバラモン人が何を捨てるべきですかというと
物に対する執着なんですよ
物ではなかったんです
例えば子供に執着する
何の意味もないんですよ
じゃあ執着しない だから子供を捨てますよと
それも間違いですよ どうせ子供っていうのは捨てなくても出て行っちゃいますよ
だから執着さえ捨てれば
子供を捨てる必要はないんです
面倒は見るんだけど 育ててはあげるんだけど
執着はないんだと 出て行ったならば
出て行ったか まあ終わりと
それで割り切っちゃえばいいんです
そう割り切れないでしょうね
子供は独立しようと思ったら頑固と反対するでしょうに
それで苦しみが生まれてくる
例えば よく子育ての問題についてね
いろいろ話を聞かされますが
問題はいつでもこの私は聞いたところで
母親の限りない無知と執着にあるんですよ
よくよく話を聞くと 別にそんなに大胆な問題じゃないんです
ごくありふれた どこにでもある
どんな子供でもやる同じことなんですよ
どんなこともね 学校に行きたくないとかね
あの学校の連中嫌だとかね
先生なんかは嫌いですよとかね
そんなことはそっちを言うでしょうね
でも この執着ある母親にとっては
それは我慢できなくなるんですよ
それで間違った態度を取る
結果として子供は間違った行動をする
それで二人とも不幸になる
で それもう一つは お釈迦様の経典から一つ引用はいたしませんですけど
あまりものすごい長い経典のテーマ
ポイントだけ説明します
お釈迦様がこの 世間から離れて
欲から離れて心を清らかにする
出家者は比丘はどのようにするべきかということのポイントの経典で
で 例えば人が村で町で生活する人というのは出家者ですね
村で町で生活すると大変面倒くさいんだと
うるさいし いろんなものがあるんだから欲が生まれてくるし
修行にはなりませんと思って
人の声も聞こえない森に入るんだと
宗教の世界で この森に入って山に入って修行することはえらいありがたいと思っていますよ
仏教の世界でもアランヤというのは森のことで
もうテーラワーダの世界でもアランヤ派といってその宗派まであるんですね
我々は出家してアランヤに生活しているんだと
他のお坊さんたちは町で生活しているので
それに対立して自分たちがアランヤ派で
まあ林尽派ですか 森林派というんですね
日本語で そういうことを本当にお釈迦様はすごいと思っているかと
そこでお釈迦様は経でこう言うんですよ
もしある修行者が森に入ったとする
森の中で生活していると
なかった煩悩が生まれるならば
ある煩悩もどんどん成長するならば
その森の生活はやめた方がいいと
ただ単に形だけで森にいても意味がないということなんですね
例えば森に入ったとする
いきなり寂しくなるかもしれません
人の顔を見られませんし
一言葉をしゃべる相手もいないし
寂しくなる可能性あります
それでまるっきり一人でいると
すごい大変なことなんですよ
皆さんもちょっとちょっと味わってみた方がいいんですよ
1日 2日間ぐらい誰とも喋らないで
テレビも見ないで 新聞も見ないで生活してみてください
これはどれくらい大変なことかと
で そうやって森の中に入ったら
その人にとってはもう夜なんかはね
いろんなことを思い浮かぶでしょうね
家にいた時は この時間になってくると子供は遊んでいるんだとかね
で 家の自分の奥さんもいろいろ料理作ったり
いろんなことしたり まあいるでしょうとかね
寝るときは一緒に まあ子供自分のところに入り込んできて
一緒に寝るでしょうとかね
朝になってくると まあ家にいただったらね
朝だったら起きてあっち行ったりこっち行ったりするんではないかとかね
そういうことを思い浮かんじゃうとどうなるんですかね
どんどん欲が増えてくるんですよ
精神的にショック受けちゃうんですよ
であるならば まあ山を下りろと
意味がないんだと その修行の
じゃあ村に生活する出家者はどうですかと
もし村に生活すると 女性の方々やら
すごい豊かな人々やら
すごいごちそうを食べている人々やら
お祭りやったり ものすごい元気で遊んだり
人々やら見ると まあ悔しくてたまらないと
やっぱり惜しいなとかね
昔だったら自分もね そういうふうに遊んだのにとかね
思ったりしちゃうと 自分の出家が嫌になってくるんですよ
そういう人だったら物に生活してはいけないと
だからお釈迦様の出家っていうのは
この隣人派とか そういう宗派に分けたわけじゃなくて
物を捨てるやり方ではなくて
心にある執着捨てるやり方なんです
だから全く都会で生活しながらも悟りを開いた人々がいるし
都会でまるっきりダメで
村に入って人が少ないところで修行して悟った人々もいましたし
それもダメで 山の中に入って森に入って修行した人々もいましたし
だから捨てる教えなんですけど
捨てるのは物ではありません
物に対する執着 そこでこのスッタニパータというテキストに出てくる言葉なんですが
ある哲学者というか 宗教思想家なんですけど
彼がこの芸で 歌でこう言うんですね
このカーマ 欲というのは
この世の中である美しいもの
全部カーマ欲ですよと
なんか当たってるような気がするでしょ
世の中に美しいものはいっぱいあるでしょうね
いわゆる心 心が惹かれるもの
今も言ったような財産やら美しい人々やら
仲のいい友達たちやら
いろんなものがありますね
楽しいものいっぱい そういう楽しいものが欲であると
だってそういうものをやっちゃうと
心にどんどん欲が生まれてくるんだから
そういう欲であると言ったら
仏教の答えは この世の中にある美しいものは欲ではありません
一つも綺麗な人々も お祭りもパーティーも欲じゃないんだ
そんなことは もう家族もなんだかんだ
そういうのは欲ではありません
欲っていうのは 心の中にあるその感情ですよ
ですから 現代日本語で言えば
花を見たら はあ きれいだ
欲しいなと思っちゃうでしょうに
悪いのは花ではないんですよ
こいつは悪いんだと 私の心に欲が作ったんだと
例えば 若い男性の人がすごい綺麗なもう人を見る
美人を見る 見たらいきなり心の中でも欲が生まれてくる
そうするとやっぱり美人が悪いんだと
心に欲が生まれたんだからと思うのは間違いなんですよ
悪いのは自分なんです
で そこでパーリ語で言えばサンカッパラーガ
プリサッサカーマ サンカッパラーガとかいうものについて妄想する
考えること自体が欲であると
例えば花を見たら花ですと終わっちゃえば
そこで欲生まれません
これは何の花ですか？どんな色ですか
ああ 欲しいですね これは自分の家に持ってきて
玄関かこういうところにあのもう花瓶に挿しておけば
やっぱりさすが綺麗でしょうとかね
あるいは植えている花を見ていたら
やっぱり自分の家でもね
前に玄関のところにこんな感じの花を植えておけば
やっぱり綺麗でしょうとか
そういうふうに妄想を働かすことによって欲が生まれてくるんです
執着が生まれてくるんです
だから物が悪くはないんです
だから やけになって物を投げ捨てたっても
それは仏教的な道ではありません
そこは全くインドでは何かよくあるみたいんですよ
この NHK のいくつか昔
いくつかの番組を見たんだけども
修行に行かなくちゃあかんとかね
修行でいったってあれは何といいますか
巡礼 巡礼に行かなくちゃあかんとか
そういうくだらん話を作ってしまって
もう長い間  2 3 年からもそこで平気で結婚して
家族もいるのに 平気でこの男の人たちがいきなり巡礼に行く
だからインド文化では巡礼に行くときはお金が要りません
ただ出て行けばいいんです
巡礼者だから みんな食べるものやら着るものやら
もう 寄付するんですよ
でお金もくれるんですよ
それで人からご飯もらうわ
寝るところももらうし
必要なお金もちょっとちょっともらうし
そこでご飯ない場合はそれで買って食べればよろしいし
それであっちこっち あの山この山とかね
回っちゃうんです 家族はどうなるんですかと
それで NHK 主催で出したのは
この 14歳の 12 4歳かな
男の子何人か撮っていたんだけど
家になんか兄弟4人ぐらいいて
その小さな子は学校にも行かないで
いろんなものを駅で水やらなんとか何とか売って
ほんのちょっとお金儲けて
またそれで材料を買って夜家に入っちゃって
もう 14歳の男の子なんですよ
自分の妹たちに料理作って食べさせる
なんで残酷な生き方かというと
それでその子供に聞いたのは
あんた学校なんかに行きたくないんですかと
学校に行って勉強したいんだと
でも妹たちが 3人いるんだから
もう学校にも行けないんだと
お金もないんだと でお父さん
お父さんは巡礼に行っているんだと
何日で帰ります？わかりませんと
もう何年も帰りませんと
一回帰って また 2 3週間で出て行ったんだと
自分一人勝手に聖者ぶりをやったりして
あれぐらい家族を不幸にする道っていうのは
それはもう どう見ても認めたくない
認める 認めるわけにはいかないんでしょうに
そういう無責任な生き方ではなくて
このこれは心の問題なんですね
煩悩というものも 執着というものも
ああいうのは無責任な責任逃れというか
夜逃げというか いい加減というか
わがままというかね それで心清らけになると思ったら
これ大違いですよ よく言うことは
ではお釈迦様も自分の奥さんと息子を置いておいて出家したのではないかと
みんな忘れることは お釈迦様は貧しい人でしたかね
えらい豊かな人で あまりにも贅沢
増長節する贅沢な生き方をした人でしょうに
そこで釈尊の王になる人で一人もそこでしたしね
ソウドーナ国王の でお釈迦様が考えたのはそういう考え方じゃないんですよ
みんな自分に期待しているんだと
希望の星が生まれたんだと
であまりにもものすごい頭が良くて
天才で それはもう釈尊も巨大な国民に国にしてくれるだろうと
だから大体伝説の話を見れば
この全国王と言ったっても
まあ昔も恐らくすべての世界というのは
おそらくインドぐらいのことだと思いますけど
すべての国々を治めるんだと
チャッカワッティという名前の王になるんだと
それは英訳するとユニバーサルモナークと訳するんだけど
全宇宙ユニバースの王にはなりっこはないんだけど
まあ当時そのストーリーを作った人々はね
インド以外国々あったかどうか
もうそれはちょっとわかりませんだけど
とにかくインドぐらいでも治めるでしょうということかもしれません
あれぐらい能力あればできないわけでもないし
今もお釈迦様は世間ね
かなりの方のコントロールしているんだから
もう最近崩れたんだけど
まあ前はね 世界で一番大きい人口は仏教徒でしたから
まあですから このそれぐらい能力あったんだから
希望の星でしたから お釈迦様は真面目に考えたんですよ
こんなまあご飯食べて
単なるもうみんなの日常生活のことにちょっと愚痴を出したりぐらいでね
この人生の問題は解決できませんと
ということで 家を出たんであって
無責任で 私が亡くなったら
この奥さんには食べるものなくなるんだとかね
この子供にも誰が面倒見るんですかとか
それは至っても面倒見ないんですよ
再婚でいてもそちらには召使いやらいろいろ家来がいるんだから
ですから お釈迦様の出家っていうのは
もういい加減無責任で出たことではなくて
それはまあ 豊かな人がもう
みんなのために出て行ったことで
そういうことで  このただ無責任にものを捨てるということは
決して執着を捨てることにはなりません
それはかえって怒りか
あるいは自分の弱み 責任を果たせない
だから言い訳して逃げる
現代社会ではね もう世界でよくありますよ
そういう宗教に興味あるという
瞑想に興味あると あっちこち地球上を回っているんですよ
あ これは新しい時代だとか言ってますが
私はそんなもういい加減だと
おかしいんだと そういう歩き回っている人々がほとんどものにならない
あの国に行って 二 三週間
一ヶ月とか なんとかなんとかやって
次の国に行って 二 三ヶ月間そちらに行って
で 威張るんです 私はネパールに行って瞑想したんだ
インドリシケシに行って瞑想したんだ
ミャンマーにも行ったんだ
タイにも行ったんだとかね
それからフランスにもなんとかの道場に入って
そのそちらの修行もしてみたんだとかね
結局聞きたいのは あんた何を得たんですかというと
ただのアホですからね
何も知らないだけで終わっちゃうんですよ
だからこの現代社会でも
そういう精神世界に興味あるという人々いるんだけど
よく見るとただの失敗作なんですよ
社会の 仕事をしたくない
あるいは親とうまくいかない
あるいは西洋人だったらすっごい激しい競争的な社会だから
何か怖くなって 何か怖くなって腰抜けて逃げちゃうんですよ
そこで東洋の神秘を目指して
ものにならないんですよ
それでものになる西洋人もいますけど
それはもうちゃんと大学
高校 大学を卒業して いくらか仕事をしてみて
本当に知識的にやっぱり興味が出てきて
やっぱりこれ知らなきゃ
西洋の文化っていうのはもう知り尽くしたと
まあそんなにあまり意味がないんだと
行って どこかに行って真面目に勉強したり
真面目に修行したりする場合は
もう本当にもう立派で役に立ちますけど
だから この 世俗的な生き方を失敗する人は出家も失敗するんですよ
心が悪いんだから 考え方がおかしいんだから
だから逃げただけで何も問題解決しません
だからそこら辺ですね
我々はちょっと混乱しているのは
ただものを捨てた それでしっかりしたわけじゃないんですね
やっぱり成功する人が成功できるような思考を働いている人が
在家であろうとも成功する
出家であろうとも成功する
そこで勘違いして欲しくない
在家で成功っていうのは豊かになることなんですけど
出家で成功することはすごい金持ちになることじゃないんです
それは精神的な世界で成功する
それは日本でよく勘違いしているんです
宗教一つ作って もう会社２つ ３
つ作ったよりも金持ちになってやるぞと
それはもうえらい勘違いで
だから宗教の世界に入る方々いるでしょうに
次に宮殿のような建物をあっちこっち作って
王様のごとく生活する
みんなからお金だまし取って
だから在家でお金だましちゃったら
もう行く先が決まってるんだから
そこで出家という出家じゃなくて
宗教という よそって人を騙すと同じ
もう騙し屋なんですよ
そういうものに我々はすぐもうかえって騙されちゃいます
見抜くことはできないんですね
だから このお釈迦様の智慧があれば
それは簡単に見抜くことはできるんですよ
だから 物事をしっかり考え
例えばバラモンのあの行者のストーリーから考えちゃうと
その人が別に心を清らかにしたければ
家ででもできたはずなんですよ
家ででも無執着の生活をできたはずなんです
それはもののせいやと思ったんですね
自分の心が汚れるの 行って
腰に巻ける巻くだけの布一つ持って行ったんだけど
結局元の生活に戻るようになってしまったんです
だから インチキのインチキ生活になってしまってなってしまったんですね
で そういう働きなんですから
仏教でいうこの 執着っていうのは
一つの心の状態な物事をわかってない状態なんですよ
だから 高級なブランドのものがあったら幸せだと思っちゃうと
頭がおかしい 頭が病気
そういうふうに思った方が
フランス製 イタリア製のカバンがあれば
自分が幸せだと それぐらい自分の心はくだらないものですかね
2  3年でボロボロになるものに任すんですかね
自分の心の幸せっていうのは
だからその思考自体がおかしいんですね
ものにとらわれると だからといってそんなものを使うなよという話じゃないんです
そんなにカバンでもってかけてるメガネのブランドでもって着ている服でもって自分を偉いと見せかけることはいかにおかしいかと
それだけなんですよ 人格者はもうブランドの品物を身に着けてあってもなくても人格者でしょうに
だから人格者がそういうものを着てはいけないというふうに変な話をするんです
お金さえあれば 余裕があれば
もう高級なものを使ってもどうってことないんですよ
でもそれにとらわれるなよと
それこそ命だと思うなよと
心は別なものですよ 本当の幸せっていうのは
物があっても幸せ なくても幸せ
だからお釈迦様の教典の中であるのは
やっぱりこの私たちはこの
お釈迦様はよく激しくそういうのは批判的に言ってますけどね
ただ服を着ていない インドである宗教がありましてね
ジャイナ教というね 服は着ません
裸でいるんですよ なんで裸でいるんですか？というと
何も物を持たないという主義なんです
でお釈迦様が聞くのは
あんた方はもう全て全て裸でいるということでね
それで心が清らかになるんですかと
物が心を汚したんですか？ということなんです
ただ文化的にできなくなっちゃった
行儀が悪くなっただけじゃないかと
礼儀作法を守らなくなっただけでしょうと
でもそのその宗教のジャイナ教の行者たちも
座るものと何かいくつか道具を持っています
そうするとそのものに執着する
だから このものが悪いということは
この私が悪いのは他人のせいだということなんですね
私がもう本当は悪くない
今悪くなっているのは周りのせいだと
それは仏教では成り立たない話なんですよ
学校のせいで子供には勉強できなかったと言ったら
もともとその子供の心が悪いでしょうに
社会のせいで 周りのせいで私はこうなったんだと
よく人のせいにする もののせいにする
でもそれは受け取ったのは自分でしょうに
人にいじめていじめられても
それはどのように受け取るかということは
自分の能力次第でしょうに
で 気が弱くなって 絶望感に追われて落ち込むか
それに適切に明るく対応するか
どちらか自分にできるでしょうに
判断することは 頭さえしっかり働かすんだったら
もう何いつでもどんな問題も乗り越える方法はあるんですよ
それはない人々がいつでももののせいに
社会のせいにする  執着のそれを一つの側面だけ説明してましたけど
またいろいろ側面があります
執着があればあるほど人は暗くなっちゃうんですよ
すごく暗くなっちゃうんです
あれは自由が失うことと同じ
例えばすごい物惜しみ状態になっちゃうと
もうやがてもう友達にも会うこともなくなっちゃって
家から一歩も出ないようにもなる場合もあります
そこで家に対しすごい執着がある場合は
どこか外国に旅行に行ったってもなかなか楽しめないんですよ
家はどうだ 誰か入ったんでしょうかとかね
だからずっともう 例えば 4 日間
5 日間ぐらいしか外国に行かないんだけど
それでも 1 日 3回  2 3回ぐらい電話かけてみる
そこで家から出ても携帯持って家にもう 1 日 10回
10回  15回  20回ぐらいも電話かけたりするとかね
そういうことでもうなかなかこの自由がなくなっちゃって暗くなるという
ものから離れなくなっちゃう
仏教でよく言うのは餓鬼道という話があるんですね
餓鬼道というのは やっぱりこの
あまりにも執着しすぎると過ぎると
死んでもこの世の中にこのものに囚われちゃって
すごい悪い不幸なところに生まれ変わっちゃうんだと
という その次元は餓鬼道というんですね
で 次にこのモノに対することを喋りましたけど
次に執着っていうのは
大変な執着がありまして
自分の意見に対する執着
概念に対する執着 それまたすごい怖いものなんです
意見 概念 自分が勉強したもの
そういうものに対する執着が入っちゃうと
その人にはかすかにも進歩がなくなっちゃうんです
ものすごく硬くなっちゃって
傲慢になって 人の話も聞けない
ものすごい恐ろしいことになります
すごい仏教はもう大変
あれよりも物に対する執着っていうのは
もう一旦ひどい目に遭ったらね
なくなりますからね 例えば
結婚 2度失敗した人がもうこりごりだという場合もあるでしょうに
もうもうこりごりだと
だから そうやってものにとらわれてものにやられた場合も
その執着はもう消える可能性はありますけど
簡単に でも思考に対する執着っていうのは恐ろしいものなんですよ
それは人間の脳細胞の開発はそのまま止まってしまっちゃうんです
仏教の考え方は どんな概念にもとらわれるなよと
どんな概念にも 我々はそうじゃないんですね
自分が小さい時からいろんなことを知って
聞いて 勉強したりして
自分というものを作っちゃうんですね
それですごく硬くなって
私はこういうものだと
私は芸術家だと 私は音楽家だと
私はなになに家だと なになにとか何とか言ったりして
他のものは全くもう聞こうと知ろうともしない
そこでこのよくあの いろいろ会議とかありますね
何かの問題があったら
どうですか？あなたはどう思いますか？あなたはどう思いますか？という
会議っていうのは みんなそれぞれの人が持っている知恵を出して
より良い決断というか
対策を作ることでしょう
ああいうのは一つも役に立たないんですね
会議やっても時間とお金の無駄
なぜかというと みんなみんなの顔色を見て何も言わない
そこで凶暴な人は自分を持ったことを言い出しちゃったら
あんたどう思いますか？いや
あれ それ結構な意見だと思いますよと
それで話し合いにも会議にもならないんですよ
で なぜ自分の意見を言わないかと
言うと二人とも悪いんですよ
凶暴な意見を言った人に対して
私は違うと思いますと言ったら
その凶暴な人はものすごく怒る
あんた何様だと思っているんでしょうかとかいう状態に怒るんですね
そうすると 言った人の立場がなくなっちゃうんですよ
クビになる可能性もあります
だから意見があっても言えない
なぜならば 受ける側があまりにも強情
あまりにも自分の意見が正しいと思っているだからなんです
そこでもう一つ 自分の意見こそこそと言ったところで
他の人々の反対の意見があって
自分の意見が潰れると
ものすごく嫌になっちゃうんですね
自分を潰したと勘違いするんです
意見が潰されただけなんですけど
そこでプライドが傷ついちゃって
いわゆる批判は怖がるんです
反対意見が怖がるんです
反対意見を怖がるんだから
自分の意見があっても言わないで
何とか何とか言ってうまくごまかす
という だから言葉が曖昧
生き方が曖昧 思考が曖昧
だから世界まるごとに曖昧
何をやっているか分からない
そこで仏教に対して対して反論したっても
もう一言葉で壊されるぐらいのバカバカらしい質問を出したり
質問ではなくて反論出したりする
質問は別にどんな質問でも結構ですけど
例えば 執着によって人が人を殺したりもする
戦争したりもする 親がもう大変苦労したりする
みんな過労になって死んだりもする
大損もしたりする それなのにやっぱり執着はもう捨てるわけにいきません
執着したらダメですよと
とまた逆に言う どっちですか？と
世の中を見てないだけなんですね
だからなぜ我々は曖昧かということは
大体この思考 自分の思考にあまりにもとらわれすぎて
人間というのは自分を思ったことを正しいと思うんですよ
母親が自分が思ったことを正しいと思って子供に喋る
子供が自分が思ったことを正しいと思っているんですよ
そこでお互いに喧嘩になって
仲良く楽しく生きていられるのに
それは壊れてしまうんですよ
だからほとんどの世の中の喧嘩っていうのは
食べ物を奪うための喧嘩じゃないんです
この思考のぶつかりなんですよ
大体現代社会でどこかの国がね
食べ物がなくて困っているんだと思ったら
それなりに助けてあげたりしますから
問題ないんですよ 例えば北朝鮮が食糧がないんだとからといって
ただその理由で韓国を攻めることはしません
もし思考がぶつかっちゃったら
もうどうなるかわからない
自分の意見ぶつかっちゃったら
だって自分が正しいんだからね
たとえ国がまあそこでも政治システムが無茶苦茶で
国が貧乏になっても 自分が思っている思考が正しいとよく言うこと
だから世の中にすごい不幸や対立やら出てくるのは
自分の意見正しいと 宗教の間でもものすごい恐ろしい争いやるでしょうに
なぜかというと その各宗教が自分の意見こそ正しいと思っているんだからなんです
でないと別に喧嘩する必要はないんです
それぞれ単なる見方だけですよと
だから ものに対する執着の次に
この自分の思考に対する執着っていうのはものすごい
恐ろしいことだと思った方がいいんです
例えば 科学者の方がこちらに来たとしましょう
で 私はもう科学っていうのはそんな大したことないと言ったら
その人はあんた何言うんですか？と
科学こそ万能ではないかということで
もう喧嘩になるんですね
それで私も自分が言ったことは厳密に正しいと思ったならば
もう お互いにやり合っちゃうんですよ
それで終わらないで 永久的にその人の顔を見たくないんだというところまで行っちゃうんですね
ただの概念なのに ただ思ったことなのに
だから楽な生き方っていうのは
それ何もそうやって頑固と思っていない方が
よ その場でその場でいろんな意見はできますから
頭の中で それはその場の意見であって
また違う意見が入ったら
それはもう調整しますよと
例えば会議なんかでは
一応私が集めたデータによると
私はこういう結論に至りましたが
いろいろ調整いたしますので
反対意見やらいろんな意見を出してくださいと
それで全く反対意見だったところで
本当の人だったらそれこそすごくありがたがるんですよ
あら 真っ向から反対意見が出たんだと
ということは 自分が見てない側道で側面で自分が扱っていないデータをその人が扱っているんだと
あ これは何なのかと 自分には開いていなかったドアでしたからね
それ自体がありがたがらないと
我々はそうじゃないんですよ
反対意見を言う人はみんな敵に回しちゃって
賛成派だけで行動しようとする
それもまたどんどん成長がなくなってしまう
とにかく物に対する執着よりも恐ろしいのは自分の意見に対する執着なんです
仏教的にものを見ると
人の意見は正しくないんですが
その人っていうのはもう何か何かの経験を何とかの角度で見て
そういう結論になっているぐらいのことで
だからその人については
それは正しい意見だと
例えば 昔の人々は地球は平らだと思っていたでしょうに
今はそれは間違っているんだと言うんだけど
私はそうは言いたくないんですよ
当時の人間が自分住んでいる世界を見て
これは平らですよと だから入ったデータを見て
それで結論を出したんですね
それで現代人が自分に入るデータによって
これ平らなものではないと
だから昔の人間が原始時代での自然を見たら
やっぱり 全部神様が作ったんだと
なぜかと考えてみたら
自分がいて 自分の母親がいて
母親の母親がいて その母親の母親がいて
それで狂っちゃうんですね
やっぱり簡単便利なのは
まず誰かが作ると それから生まれていくのはもう簡単ですよ
それはその人々に入ったデータによって至った結論なんですね
我々から考えちゃうと
だから人類はみんな同じ女の人から生まれたんですかと
そこはその人たち知らなかったんですよ
また他の国もあるんだと
どうかね 格好をつけてこすこすとくだらんことを考えちゃうと
そういう風にもう 初めの人がいて
女がいて そこからみんなで生まれていったと言っただけ
だからそういうのは間違いでも正しいでもなく
そのその人々に入ったデータによって至った結論なんですよ
それでお釈迦様がその説明すると
このデータは認めるんですね
結論は認めないんですよ
だから一番良いのは そうやって頑固と結論に至らないことなんです
これ 業の説明する経典で
ある経典がございます
中部経典なんですが 業
カルマ カルマのことを説明するとこう言うんですよ
ある修行修行者が出家して
厳密に 修行して超能力を得られるんだと
超越した能力を得られるんだと
得られて 彼にはこのいくらか物事を見られる能力つくんだと
ついたところで ある人のことを観察すると
そこでその人が何者かで見たら
殺生するは嘘をつくはもうよこしまない行為をするとかね
そうやって悪悪事を犯している
そこでその人が死んで死ぬ
死んだらどこに生まれ変わったかと自分の能力で見たら
まあ悪いところに不幸なところに生まれ変わっているのは見られる
見られると彼が結論を出す
やっぱり悪事を犯したら不幸になるんだよと
それこそ事実だと もし人が違うことを言うならば
それは間違いだと と説法するんだと
またもう一人の行者が同じく修行して
超越した能力を得て またある人を観察するんだと
観察したら その人は殺生もしないし
盗みも働かないし 何も悪事をしない
すごい善行為をしている
そこでやがてその人は死ぬ
死んだところでどこに生まれ変わったかと見ると
経典は長いんだから その人は天国にいるのを見つかるとかって
そこはちょっと省いて
まあまだある行者がそうやって人を見る
悪事を犯している人を見る
人を見たら その人死んだところでどこに生まれ変わったかと見る
見ちゃうと なんでこの人天国に生まれ変わっているんだね
自分がその人が生きていた時
どんなことをやったかと見たところで
もう悪事を犯してたんですよ
殺生やら盗みやらなんだかんだ十悪ありますから
で 死んで生まれ変わった
どこに生まれ変わったかというと
天国にいるんではないかと
大変幸福になってしまう
そこでその行者がこう決めるんだそうです
やっぱりこの悪事を犯しても
先行したってもね まあ大した意味がないと
いわゆる悪行為には悪結果
悪い結果がないんだと
なぜならば 私は何々さんを観察したところで
その人が今天国に生まれ変わっているのは
私は見たんだから それは事実ですよ
言って行為を否定する
また一人の行者がそうやってある人を観察しちゃうと
善行為を行っている人がいて
その人が死んでどこに生まれ変わったかを見ちゃうと
地獄に落ちているのが見られるんですね
それでその人もやっぱりあれほど先行したっても
死んでから地獄に落ちてるんだから
やっぱり善行為には結果がないんだと
と決めちゃうんだ そこでお釈迦様はそういう例を全部並べてこう言うんですよ
そのその行者が観察したのも認める
観察してた人が善行為をやっていたんだと
それでその善行をやった人が死んでから天国に行ったっていうことを
私はそれを事実だから認めますと
でもその行者の言い方はね
結論は認めませんと で
一番はっきりわかるのは
例えば良いことをした人が地獄に落ちると
お釈迦様は良いことをしたことを認めるんだと
地獄に落ちたことを認めるんだと
でも結論は認めませんと
なぜならば 彼らの観察方法は間違っているんだと
ですから ちゃんと順番で原因結果の順番できちんと観察するべきですよと
善行為をした人も 例えば死んでから地獄に落ちたならば
その人はその善行為をする以前
悪行為を犯したことがあるかもしれません
あるいは善行為をして
その時後で死ぬちょっと前でも心が汚れたかもしれませんと
そこはそちらは観察していないんだと
ですから このデータは認めるんだけど
いい加減にまとめて結論を出すことは否定しちゃうんですね
そこら辺を説明しちゃうと難しくなりますね
だからまあ話は他の方向へ持っていきますけど
この私たちは自分の意見にしがみつくことは危険です
なぜならば 自分がすべて知っているわけじゃないんです
すべてがすべての尺度で見たわけじゃないんです
たまたまちょっと一つだけ見ただけ
例えばこちらで来て ある人が喧嘩したとする
それで私たちは何々さんがとんでもない行儀の悪い怒りっぽい悪人だと決めつけちゃうと
その結論が間違っている
何々さんがこの勉強会に来て喧嘩したんだよという事実は正しいんです
だから我々言うべきなのは
この勉強会に来た時だけ
勉強会に来た時 その人の生き方が良くなかったと
私たちのやり方はそうじゃない
その人は全体的に否定する
あいつは悪人だと あの結論がまるっきり間違ってるんですよ
その人は小さい時 どんな性格でしたか？学校でどんな性格でしたか？家庭でどんな人ですか
会社でどんな人でわかるもんですかね
何一つも調べてないんです
そこである人がすごい良いことをやろうと
立派に行動しようと 有名になって頑張ろうとすると
そんなこと今さら言ったっても
この人は 23 歳でどこかでなんとかして警察に取り調べたことがあるんだと
故に悪人やと それ言えますかね
そんなことは 例えばもう二十歳頃
いろいろ麻薬もやってみたりとかね
いろいろ女性がいるところに行って遊んだりとかね
そこでもう捕まったりとかね
したことがあったかもしれませんだけど
それからはどんどん良い人間になって
立派な人間に後でなりえないんですかね
なることはできないんだ
できますよ だから人間の思考というのはそうじゃなくて
自分何かいい ただ 例えば立派な人がいる
その人は潰しちゃいいんだ
潰したいという気持ちが生まれてくる
その先に感情が出てきて
先に答えが目的が出てきて
その目的を達するために必要なポイントだけ取る
他のポイントを消す そういうことだから
どんな人間でも だから自分の意見にとらわれることは一番危険なんです
ですから 人間いういろいろ意見があるでしょ
まあくだらんというと
これは何一つの意見というのは
知識的に正しい意見は残念ながらならないんですよ
それぞれ自分の感情で語る
例えば現代若者の生き方が良くないという意見を持ってる人だったら
その人を調べるデータはすべて若者の間違いだけ取ってきて見せて
見てごらんなさいと 現代若者の立派なところは全然無視と
ある政治家を潰したければ
その人をやった悪いことだけ調べてそれを出す
でも人間というのは純粋に悪いことだけするわけじゃないでしょうに
だったらそういうふうな偉い人にならないでしょうに
純粋に良いこともできるわけじゃないでしょうに
それはすごく面白いのは
アメリカの政治の世界で
もう大統領選挙なんか出たら
一生懸命反対側が何を調べるかというと
生まれた瞬間からその瞬間までの全部調べて
すべてどこかでもないか
何かおかしいことをしたことがないかと
大体誰かの女性の体を触ってもう事件になったこと
それだけでもいいんですよ
それでこの女性に殴られちゃって会社クビになったと
今は大金持ちで大統領選挙に出ているからあれ出すんですね
いかにくだらなくて アホかというと
英語を読めるならば アメリカの新聞もざんざん出ますから
インターネットで読んでみてください
これは世界支配している立派な人間ですかと
新聞なんか見ると品のないこと
やっぱりたとえアメリカにしろとも
他の国にしろとも やっぱり人間は人間だから
まあろくなことじゃないんですよ
大したことないんですよ
だから自分を出したい意見だけ言うために何か
データ集めていったりする
そういうことですから
この我々はそこら辺気を付けるとかなり無執着の生き方ができるんですよ
物はそんなに問題じゃないんですよ
いくら欲しくて欲しくて
例えばもう 4年間  5年間お金が貯まって何か買ったりしたっても
それは壊れちゃったらまあしょうがないやともう諦めますからね
物に対する執着っていうのはそれほど問題じゃないんですよ
例えば 10年ローンで車買ったりする
そこはもうスピード出したところでもうもう潰れてしまったと
ああ 悔しいなというぐらいで
もう終わっちゃいますよ
でも 意見に対する執着はそんな生易しいものじゃないんです
そういうことだから 自分の意見に対する執着ということは大変気をつけてください
意見自体もおかしいんですよ
それは自分の都合によって自分が作るものであって
事実を語っているわけじゃないんです
で  3番目の恐ろしい執着っていうのは
まあ自分に対する執着ということでね
生きていきたいと まあ死にたくはないんだと
自分がいるんだという
それは基本的なところで
どうもこのものを見たり聞いたり
喋ったり考えたりすると
なんか自分がいるんだ
いるんだという錯覚は必ず生まれるんです
何か目を開けて見たら
私が見たと 耳に音が入ったら私が聞いたと
で 味わった時も 日本語ではちょっと言いにくいんだけど
まあ私には美味しかったと
足が痛いんだったら 私の足が痛いんですと
そういうふうに思うんだから
この私がどこにいるんですかね
私が見たと言葉で言うんだけど
その見た私がどこにいるんですかね
見るということを科学的にはっきりしていますからね
目を通してもう光の反射したね
データが脳細胞に入って
電気信号を起こして 脳細胞の中でちょっと電気信号を起こすだけでしょ
それも脳の構成によって何見るかどうかはわからないんですね
だから我々は本当にあるものは見てないんですよ
幻覚なんです 頭の中で見ているのは
幻覚だから 例えばある絵は私が綺麗と思っちゃうし
ある人は綺麗じゃないと思っちゃうしね
事実見るんだったらみんな同じ意見言うでしょ
だからその頭の中でこの幻覚作っちゃうんですね
だから見るっていうことは
それぐらいのこと そこでそれくらいに私いるわけじゃないんです
味わう時でも同じことで
私の足というと 私の手
私の首 私の心臓 そうやって全部私の方であって
私はどこですかね 体の至る所
取ってみたら これは私のであって私ではありませんでしょ
髪の毛見たって私の髪の毛であって
髪の毛が私ではありません
目は私の目であって 目が私ではありませんでしょうに
それで意見についてあっても
これは私の意見であって
意見が私ではありませんでしょ
悲しみについてあっても
これは私の悲しみであって
悲しみが私ではありませんね
楽しみの場合も同じことなんですね
私が楽しむ楽しんで楽しいであって
楽しみが私ではありません
この私がどこにいるんですかね
とにかくそれは化け物なんですよ
だから逃げる これじゃない
別ですよ これじゃないですよ
ですよと 時々人が私の手に殴ったら
私はいきなりなんで私を殴るんですか？と私は反論するでしょ
そうするとその人が私は手殴ったんだけど
あんた殴ったことないんですよと言ったら
いえ これ私の手ですよと言っちゃうでしょうに
だから初めは手は私でしたけど
これはちょっと話して
いや 逃げるんですよ 私が手が私のもの
そこで聞けば その私がどこにいるんですかと
見つからないんです どこまででも逃げる
化け物ですからね で そういうものだから
我々はずっと私がいるという前提で生きているんですね
それは一番取りにくい執着なんです
それもものすごい不幸を作ってくるんですよ
人が手に殴ったって怒る必要ないでしょ
これ私の手だから怒るんであって
でなきゃ怒らないでしょうに
人が隣の家に泥棒が入ったって
私は平気でいるんですよ
悪口も言うんですね ろくにも鍵もかけないんだから
もう良いことだと そんなことは
そこまで言うんですよ
で 私の家に泥棒が入っちゃったら
もうすごく怒って警察に文句言うんですよ
いい加減でもう税金で食べてるだけで
もうちゃんと泥棒も捕まってこないと
誰にも悪口 なぜかというと
私の家だからなんです
人が人を殺したと聞いたっても
全然平気な顔してるんですよ
ああそうというか とりあえずはい
人が自分の誰かが殺しちゃったら
そうはうまくいかないんですね
私の息子を殺しちゃったんだよと
だから一生憎しむんだよということになっちゃうんです
だから大変なものなんです
この私って その一言葉が
それに執着しているんだから
私たちは全ての執着を作るんです
私が幸せになりたいんだから結婚するんだと
私が幸せになりたいんだから勉強する
私は幸せになりたいんだから
もう何々の偉くなるんだとか
そこで体を分解してみて
心を分解してみたら もうただただそれぞれ機能のみであって
そこに私がないとわかったら
もう一番取りにくい執着が消えちゃうんですね
それではもうそれはもう悟りの世界で私がという概念消えたら
もうもう悟ってるんですね
問題はなしと そういうふうにこの執着といったっても
こういうふうに３つに分けて考えた方がよろしいと思います
皆様方はあまり気になるのは
この 1番目ですね 物に対する執着
どうったことない そんなものはあってもなくてもどうでもいいんですよ
いっぱい財産があっても執着なしに生きていられるんです
私はそういう人々を見てきたこともありますけど
かなり恵まれていて もうもうないということは全くない状態で生きているんだけど
全く軽々しい心で すごく無執着の心でいられる
大体この過去生で この自我なしに
執着なしに 人にものを施したりしたり
すごくいいことをした人々が豊かになって生まれ変わっちゃいますよ
生まれ変わったっても
金が勝手に入るんであって
自分で儲かろうというぐらい気持ちもない
何やったっても遊びでやるんであって
やっぱりまた金が舞い込んでくる
だからで執着するから執着もしない
面白くもないんですよ
勝手に来るんだから そういう人もいてもいますよ
実際には知っている人々もいますからね
バブルになろうが何になろうが
もうその人とは関係ないんです
金入る道が変わるだけで
こういう方向で金入っていて
そこでバブルで閉ざされたら
こちらから入り込んでくるという
だから本人はやっぱり過去の習慣
癖がついているんだから
それでも全然もう物に囚われない
すごい気楽に気持ちよく
すごく明るく生きていられる
明るさは消えちゃうんです
執着が出てきて だから皆さんはよく興味ある話はっていうのは
この物に対する執着なんですけど
それはそんなに大きな大げさな問題じゃないんです
もうちょっと物事を考えれば
すぐそこはなくりますけど
じゃあ それからこの 1番目の執着に際して
我々はどうすればいいかと
そこら辺だけ説明します
例えば子供が生まれたら
これ私の子供だとと思っちゃうと執着が生まれてくる
これ 私の子供じゃないんです
私ももともとないんだから
それはもう限りない輪廻転生の中の一人の生命が自分の家に来ただけのことなんです
それでせっかく来た自分の家を選んだ人だ
お客さんだから まあ一生懸命やってあげる分はやってあげる
いくらやってあげたっても
その人は全く独立している別な人だと
自分には その人を医者にしてやるぞとかね
あるいはエンジニアにしてあげるぞとかね
そこまで決めることはちょっと失礼ですよ
結婚相手も決めてやるぞとかね
親が反対だからあんた結婚するなよとかね
そこまで行っちゃうと出てくるのは苦しみだけ
生きることはいかに楽しく楽に生きていられるかを忘れているんですね
みんな まあ高価なカバンを買っても
まあ世の中みんな言ってるんだから買っただけですよというぐらいでね
これはまあそろそろどんどんどんどんボロボロになるんだと
そんなもんだと 世の中っていうのは
家を造っても これは作ったその日からね
古くなっていくんだと
まあこれくらい年取っちゃうと
これも古くなっちゃうんだと
その前に竜巻やら台風やらいろいろね
自然災害ありますから
地震やら火事やらね まあそういうもので消えるかもしれませんと
たとえ自分が作ったばっかしの家
火事になってなくなったと
そうすると 30年のローンだけ残っちゃうでしょうに
それで執着あるとえらい苦しいんですよ
執着がないと まあまあ
大したことない そんなことはもうありえることだと
ありえることだと まあこれから頑張ればいいんじゃないかと
大体この短く考えればね
長く考えないで 今どうすればいいかと
家が火事になったら今どうするべきかというと
やっぱり こととか もう何か取れるものがあるんだったら
それ取るぐらいのことでしょうに
それからじゃあ次にどうすればいいかと
それだけ考えちゃうと結構明るく生きていられます
人間 もともと考える能力がないにも関わらず
えらい 20年計画で 40年
100年計画で考えるんですよ
私は言うのは 1 分計画で考える能力をついてくださいと
もう考える能力はないんだと
勝手だと思考自体は当てにならないんだと
大体今どうすれば良いのかというぐらいのでいいんですよ
人生は 明日 明後日 明後日
100年後になっちゃうと
もう何も考えることできないんです
妄想することしか ですから
このものに対する執着をに執着を消したければ
まあ今どうすればというぐらいの短い範囲で物事を考える
それは仏教の修行になってくると
今の瞬間というものを見られると
すべての真理はわかるんだと
すべての執着が消えるんだと
だから仏教の瞬間という真理があるでしょうに
なぜ人間に煩悩があるかというと
これは 100年計画で考えるからでしょ
時々会社を作ったら これは自分だけじゃなくて
孫もついてほしいと 息子もその会社を継いで
それから孫も継いでほしいと
執着の恐ろしさといえば
そこで その会社に次に来るバカどもの孫も
やっぱりこのおじいさんが作った会社だから
3代目だからと で  4代目までやって欲しがるんですね
100年計画じゃないんですよ
そういうのはもうすごい苦しみだけ作る
束縛される 孫にはものすごい違う才能があってもしょうがないんですよ
孫にはものすごい抜群の科学者になる能力があるとしましょう
でも おじいさんが自動車の修理工場を作ってやっているんだと
これかなり儲かってはいるんだと
それでそこを守らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
科学者を辞めて なることできない
小さい時から叩き込むんだからね
お前はこの会社は跡継ぎですよ
会社の そうすると自分の自由を失ったんだから
その孫であろうがひい孫であろうが
だいたい自由な時間はいい加減で
わがままでやりたい放題なことをやる
だってもう安定しているんだから
自分の将来は まだ面白くないしね
そういう人に入ってきたら
またその会社も潰れる
あるいはやっとした計画もそれで壊れてしまうと
そういうことになりますから
あまり長い時間に計画を立ててはいけません
すべて瞬間で変化するんだから
できれば瞬間だけで見ればもう悟ることさえもできるんですよ
だから時間が短くなればなるほど
私たちはより正しい生き方をするんです
今どうすればいいかと
今日 1 日どうすればいいかと思ったら
より正しい生き方ができるんですよ
より楽なんです 今日は 1 時間に絞って
1 分に絞っちゃうと もっともっと真理に近い生き方ができちゃうんですよ
それは瞬間に絞っちゃうと
真理はわかってしまって
悟りにまで至るんですね
だから執着をなくす方法として言えるのは
そうやって思考を短く
時間として短くすることなんです
例えば 今体の調子が悪いと思ったら
私は病気だ 私の体は調子が悪いんだと
この時間制限なしに言っちゃうでしょうに
そこで理解する人々も時間制限なしに思っちゃうんですね
そこがおかしいんです
まあ時々私も体の調子が悪い時
時々ちょっと言ったりする場合
それは遊びで言うんだけど
言う必要ないんだけど
でまあちょっと今日は体の調子が悪い
私は今日はどうか 今はどうかね
はっきりと時間制限言って言うんだけど
例えばもう朝からもう元気でいて
もう 3時半になってくると
なんか調子がなんか嫌にもう調子が悪くなったんですよと言っちゃうと
時間制限ちゃんとあるんですよ
今の時間からやと でも聞いてる方がそうじゃない
私は永久的に 体の調子が悪いと言って
一生懸命親切に考えて
私の体に悪いことばっかり持ってくるんです
私も困るんで これは気持ちはわかるし
これは一生懸命親切に考えて持ってくるんだけど
これは私には本当のところは要りませんという
もうこちらまで困る状態になっちゃうんですね
だからそれは冗談でわかりやすくするために言ったんだけど
だから今日は頭が痛いということは
永久的に頭が痛いわけじゃないんです
だから物事はちゃんと時間制限の中で考えたり行動したり
した方が一番真理に近いと思います ４
時ぐらいで終了してもいいんですかね
じゃああとちょっと５分がございまして
この私は一つものすごい長い経典を一つ持ってきたんです
で これ読み上げをしても
15分以上はかかります
で その経典にあるストーリーだけ説明します
あの お釈迦様は西行で住んでいた時
ある在家の方に一人息子がいたんだと
ものすごいかわいい息子がいて
その息子が死んでしまったと
息子が死んだ時は彼が悲しくて仕事はできなくなっちゃったと
ご飯も食べられなくなったと
彼が火葬場に行って 私の一人息子はどこに行ったんでしょうか
なんで死んだっただろうとかね
毎日泣くんだと そこで彼がお釈迦様に会うんですよ
お釈迦様に会ったら お釈迦様がその人にこう言うんですね
あんたなんか自分でないようだと
こちらにいてもいないようだと
調子が悪いんだと 体もおかしいんだと
なんかいてもボーっとしているんだからね
こちらに至っても なんかこちらにいないような感じですよと
何でしょうかと聞いたら
もう何をおっしゃるんですかと
キンチメマンディインディアなんにゃなんやったんバビスタティ
私はそんな調子にならななるのは不思議じゃないんだと
私にいた一人息子がもう死んでしまったんだ
だから私はもうずっとこちら来るまではね
何日間も毎日火葬場に行って
もう泣いて泣いて泣いてきたいたんだと
やっとちょっと落ち着いてお寺にお釈迦様に会ったんですけども
それでお釈迦様は あ それはその通りです
その通りですよ 好きなものはね
好きなものっていうのは
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみしか作ってくれないんだよと
何のことなく単純なことをおっしゃったんですよ
だからこの人はもう人が狂ったような状態でしょうね
その通りですよ この好きなものっていうのは
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみしか作ってくれないんだと
事実はおっしゃったんだけど
その人が こう言うんですよ
そんなことはありえないよと
お釈迦様はそんなことはありえないんだと
好きなものがあったあってこそ
人間に喜びも楽しみも幸福感も生まれるのではないかと言ってお釈迦様に反論しちゃったんです
反論して まあそれで説法にならないんだからね
お互いに喧嘩したっても
で 彼が帰っちゃうんです
帰っていくと その道でろくでもない人間のグループがいたんですよ
仕事もしないで まあものすごいだらしない
もう賭け事ばっかりやったり
酒飲んで賭け事ばっかりやって
まあもうそういうもうろくでもない人間のグループがいたんです
そちらはやることを仕事もしないんだからね
人のお金でも盗んで賭け事にして
それで賭けたりして またなんとか遊んだりするだけのことだからね
暇があるんですよ それでいたら
そのこのバラモン このサイキの人が通っていると
その人にあんたどこに行ってきたんですかと
言ったら 彼がそういうお釈迦様に会って帰ったんです
お釈迦様って何いう人ですかねと言ったら
お釈迦様がね この好きなものが憂い
悲しみ 苦しみの元やと言ったんだと
私はそれを反対しましたと
好きなものがあれば人間は幸せでしょう
と言ったら その人々はそれはしっかりその通りですよと
あんたは正しいんだと
人間が好きなことをやっていけば
いかに楽しいかと それが事実やと言って
あのブラフマン人を褒めたんです
ブラフマン人じゃない
この普通のサイキの人
あんたは正しいんだと
そこでこの仏教の信者さんだから
この人すごく恥ずかしくなったんですよ
自分の意見がろくでもない
仕事もしない 賭け事やら悪いことばっかりしてる人
人の意見とぴったし合うんですね
偉大なるお釈迦様の意見とは合わないんですよ
それですごく恥ずかしくなっちゃったんです
でもその結論は出てこなかったんですよ
簡単なことで そこでその話がどんどん広げていっちゃって
で コーサラ王様にその話を話して言っちゃったんですね
コーサラ王様を認めた
このやっぱり楽しいものは楽しみを作ってくれるんだという態度で
そこでお妃がいるんです
マリーカ夫人という マリーカさんは悟りを開いていて
お釈迦様の大変大事な信者さんなんですが
彼女にあんたどう思いますか？お釈迦様はなんかおかしいことをおっしゃっているのではないかと言ったら
マリーカ夫人が いや これがお釈迦様がおっしゃったならばね
まあそれはその通りですよと言っても
マリーカ夫人でもこれ説明できないんですよ
でも彼女が夜間に悟っていたんだから
いつでも自分 お釈迦様の意見はすぐもうその通りですという立場なんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
私に分からなくても間違いはずがないという立場なんです
言ったら王様がもうからかっちゃって
うまいね なんだかね お釈迦様がおっしゃったら正しいというだけで
何もわかってないでしょうと
いい加減にしなさいと
言われたマリーカ夫人も負けてはいられませんだから
で こすこすとお釈迦様の方に人が送ったんですよ
送って このことをお釈迦様に報告して
お釈迦様に説明聞きなさいよと
うーん でお釈迦様はこの人々はあまりにも頭が悪いんだから
厳密な説明しないで 簡単ないろいろストーリーを言うんですよ
昔 この同じ 西上の町でお釈迦様もある夜の
ある女がいて その女のお母さんが死んじゃったんだと
死んじゃったところで
この娘さんが頭が狂っちゃって
頭が狂ってしまったと
狂ってしまっちゃって
家を出て いろんな道路をあっちこっちあっちこっち歩き回るようになったんだと
道 町 道から道へ こっちあっち行っていて
何を？頭狂ってるんだから
何をね 私のお母さん見たの？お母さんに見たのとお母さん捜しに行ったんだそうです
この娘さんが もしかすると子供かもしれません
この経典でわかりませんだけど
子供には時々そういうこともありますからね
死んだっていうことでわからなくなっちゃって
お母さんどこ？お母さんどこ？とかね
じっと待ってるとか あるいは探しに行くとかね
頭が狂っちゃった とにかく
だから好きなものからろくな結果が出てこないんだと
その娘さんがお母さんのことを大好きで
お母さん死んじゃったと
だから頭狂っちゃったんだと
そうやっていろいろ例を出すんですね
そこでもう一つストーリーがありまして
ある ある女の人がお嫁に出しちゃったんですね
お嫁に出されるところへ
その家の人々が このお嫁さんがあまり気に入らなくて
他の人にあげたがっちゃうんですね
あんたに他の誰かを話してやってあげましょうと
で 家から出そうとするんです
でも この女の人がそれはあんまり好きじゃないんですね
それで自分の旦那に言ったんですよ
もうこの親戚が私をこの家から外へ出して
他の誰かのとこにあげたがってるんだと
私はどこにも行きたくないのです
その人は何をしたんですかというと
この人もおそらくもうあまり弱い人でしたでしょうね
両親が言うことが怖くて
親戚が言うことが怖くて
だからこの人がこの何か刃物を持ってきて
その女を刺して殺しちゃったそうです
殺して自分を自殺しちゃったんだと
二人が別れたくないんです
でも この家の関係で この女の人は他の家に出しゃって
それで離婚になっちゃいますから
自分の息子にもっと他のお嫁さんはもらえるんだからね
それでこの二人がもうどうしたっても
親戚たちに両親にもう別れさせるでしょうに
それは嫌で 女のところと自分も死んでしまったと
だから好きなことっていうのは
そうやって大変な結果は作ってしまいますよと
で そこでマリーカ夫人がその話をお釈迦様の説法を聞いて
で しっかりして王様のところに行って
あの王様は子供たちがいろいろいるんですね
例えばワーサブカッティアという
この大変綺麗な娘さんがいたんですよ
で 王様がね ワーサブカッティアって娘さんのことをどう思いますか？と
好きですか？と まあこれ大好きですよと
大好きですよと ああそう
もしワーサブカッティアがね
変な病気にかかったりして
おかしくなったりしちゃうと
あんた気持ちいいんですか？と
言ったらと言ったら とんでもないんだと
とんでもないな そんなことは思っただけでも嫌ですよ
と言ったら だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
あそこという娘のこと
あんた好きだから その彼女にちょっと何かでも病気になったらあんたがおかしくなるんだと
だから苦しみが生まれるんだと
どんどんいろいろ人のことを聞いて
最後にアンタ私のこと好きですか？と
そしたらお釈迦皇様のお気に入りなんですよ
1番目にマリカさんが頭良いよろしいし
言ったら 君のことをすごい大好きですよ
もし私が病気になって倒れたり
早く死んじゃったりしちゃうと
あんた楽しいですか？と言ったら
楽しいどころかもう嫌で狂っちゃうかもしれませんよ
だから好きなものが苦しみを作ってくるんだと
で 最後に王様は自分のことを好きですよ
好きですか？と いちいちいちそうやって質問するんですね
あんた 国のこと好きで
この国は私は大好きです
じゃあ この国は誰かに盗られたり亡くなったりして
あんたどうなるんですかね
それでは並みの悲しみを味わうでしょう
だから好きなものは悲しみを作ってくるんだと
あんたは自分の財産好きだ
財産好きです じゃあ財産なくなったんたらどうなるんですか？だからもうすごいショックを受けるでしょうと
ということで デンデンと言ったら
もう皇室様はやっぱりさすがお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは正しいんだということで
お釈迦様の意見通りますが
そこでお釈迦様が礼をするんですね
それよりか この経典の中で
この厳密にポイントはそこまで言う必要ないんだけど
あのサイケの人が 1週間ぐらいほど飲ませ食わす仕事もしないで
なぜ苦しかったかというと
子供に対してすごい愛着
執着あったんだからなんです
だから 例えば嫌な人が死んじゃったら
あんな苦しみが生まれないでしょうね
だから人間 好きなものばっかり集まりたがるんだけど
その集まる好きなものっていうのはちょっとしたことで壊れちゃいますよ
すべて壊れますからね
だから必ずも苦しみがあって
お母さん大好きですよと言うと
お父さん大好きですよと言って喜んでいたっても
そのお母さん お父さん必ず死ぬんですよ
そうすると好きな分だけ
それより何倍も苦しめなくちゃいけないんですよ
子供が生まれると ああ
もう大好きですよと 目に入れても痛くはないんですよ
と言うんだけど その目に入れても痛くない時
その子供に何かあったらどうなるんですかね
だからものすごい苦しみが生まれてくるんですよ
ですから この執着は苦しみの元なんです
作ってくる楽しみっていうのはほんのわずかなんですよ
面白くて外車でも買っても
もうそれは守る 苦しいものは大変なんですよ
気をつけて気をつけて
かすり傷でもつけないようにとかね
でもちょっとしたことで全部潰れちゃったら
ものすごい苦しみが生まれる
特に高級車の場合はかなりそう盗まれちゃいますでしょうね
安い車だったら誰も持っていかないんですけど
そうするとものすごいショックを受けちゃうんですね
愛着があればあるほどショックは受ける
諦めちゃったらね 諦めるということは
ただ諦めて馬鹿みたいにいるんじゃなくて
諦めまあということになったら
それを調べることができますよ
元気で 愛着ばっかりやっちゃうと
もう調べることも なくなったものをまた取り戻すこともさえもできなくなっちゃうんですね
だから子供に対しても
子供は育てるんであって
育てるだけのことだったら
病気になってもすごい冷静を保ってどうすればいいかということをわかるんですよ
はー 私の大事な子供だと思ったら冷静が失っちゃうんです
ですから せっかくその病気になった子供にするべき治療さえもできなくなっちゃうんですね
だから執着がないと冷静さが出てくる
それでもってみんな守られます
たとえ自分の子供が遊んで遊び始めた時
コソコソと歩き始めた時
何か捕まったり何かやったりして
ちょっと体に火でもついちゃったら
すぐ冷静さを失っちゃうんですよ
そうすると もうほんのちょっとの
損害で終わることはすごい大きくなっちゃうんですね
自分の家でちょっと火が出たっても
すごく冷静さっていうのがあれば
じゃあこういう風に消せばいいでしょうと
愛着ある人にとっては大変だ
どうしよう どうしようと
もう百搭も忘れちゃうんですね
家に消火器あってももう見つからないんで
その時に限って感情が出てくるんですね
だから いかなる場合でも
その愛着の感情が出ないように冷静にいれば
何の問題もないんですよ
すごく人生っていうのは楽しくはなります
生きることも楽しくなります
じゃ 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます